ci sono delle volte in cui vengo
tartassato per tutto il giorno di
richieste di giocare un determinato
gioco no era da tanto che non mi
succedeva per un gioco horror quindi ho
detto chissà quanto meraviglioso deve
essere perché non consigliano tutti cioè
proprio deve essere il gioco della vita
outlast in confronto deve essere il cibo
per piccioni tutti me lo hanno chiesto
quindi ho detto vabbè diamo un'occhiata
sta roba vediamo granny parte con dalla
pagina del play store vediamo come il
cielo presentano giusto per capire al
granny l'icona è titubante la madonna
secondo giochi migliori arcade non è un
horror descrizione del gioco brevissima
ma efficace
non ti tiene bloccato nella sua casa è
bellissimo non ce n'e anche troppa
velocità e la grafica è ottima hanno mai
giocato a qualcosa questi ragazzi nella
loro vita
3 2 1 let's go partiamo subito con una
copertina di dubbia provenienza
però vabbè play esci da qui hai solo
cinque giorni tutto quello di cui ha
bisogno nella casa e fai silenzio lei
sente tutto e la nonna è pazza buona
cosa
chiudiamo day1a puo aprire i cassetti
fantastico sito lascia questa casa bene
la voce ha intuito la prima audi scusi
non volevo primo dubbio incredibile che
mi sorge faceva un cazzo però che
fantasia nell'ambientazione allora prima
fare una cosa non so come si esce da
questa porta visto che è chiusa foto
casca il quadro bene allora è
nascondigli nascosti subito adesso
l'inter ha tutte incazzata però non mi
troverà perché sono sotto il letto
[Musica]
essi ibra per la porta dovevo far cadere
qualcosa a nascondermi in chiave entrate
in quella portali quindi mentre questa
si sa mai bene da una vasca da bagno o
cos'è un pezzo di quadro a lo tengo
proprio in mano ci devo andare con
questa roba in giro va bene il personas
condere negli armadietti ho trovato un
pezzo di di pinto mi sarà utilissimo
credo ma la mia nonna dove è andata
esattamente cos'è
c'è una trappola per fare fai attenzione
bravo che hai buttato tutto a terra
bravissimo non sta cucinando niente
strano molto strano e cavalcano la vista
ma basta ma di far ripartire da qua
comunque il pezzo di quadra non hanno
capito dove dovrei metterlo prove cos'è
la parte di un fucile poggiamo qua
questo è un quadro che ho buttato
ovviamente giù perché ci mancherebbe
[Musica]
chiude la parte difficile ho trovato la
seconda che non ho capito dove c'è posso
sparare a non vanno giù in cucina nonna
posso passarmi in cui storia addirittura
[Musica]
quando stai a must ha risolto non è vero
un altro pezzo di fucile se ritorno lì
sopra forse l'esca unire tutto il fucile
pezzo di quadro madonna quanti ce ne so
io ho trovato un cavalcavia via via via
veloce via un pezzo di carne
porca vacca veloce veloce veloce veloce
la bella
non ho mai capito cosa mi se resterò
taglia qualsiasi cosa sia non so cosa ma
taglia fatto c'è un'altra via quando
escono tutto nascosto in sta casa se va
beh e secondo te io leggo sta roba
comunque questa volta buona me lo sento
c'è un'unica porta che non ho ancora
visto che questa che però è chiusa più
attirano anali qualche me ne vado
orca schifosa sono libera cos'era una
trappola per orsi orribile non serve a
niente
vai vai vai perfetto la chiave della
casa giocattolo allora in teoria con
questa rai accedere esatto vice che c'è
qua dentro un altro ingranaggio dopo
quello che speravo giuro hai qualche
vanno messi gli ingranaggi
ma c'era una cantina nella cantina a me
la vedo utile comunque ragazzi secondo
me qua sotto nella cantina c'è un botto
di roba che non ho visto perché qua in
tour e tu puoi salire in macchina già
qua non ho capito se in macchina tipo
prendere o no prova mentre dovresti
alzare la porta del garage bene abb è
perfetto look and not escape
grazie ad esso si che sono a posto così
si trova attivato poi non ho capito
questo tipo va beh qualcosa verrà
attivato lo speriamo che non sia di
sorpresa palace a una cosa posso fare la
sauna gioco dell'anno
adesso ho capito i 10 milioni di
scaricamenti sono per la sauna
addirittura sono cascato nel bagno
questa parso riuscita sono riuscito a
cascare nel bagno come allora parte di
fucile e la cosa che mi interessa
moltissimo perché cielo quasi tutti in
teoria quanto può essere smontato un
fucile ma mi servirebbero i proiettili
però vabbè dettagli ma c'è un'altra roba
qua ma basta quanti posti
cos'è a era una stanza nascosta c'è un
pupazzo teddy io tratte di la parte di
un fucile perdonami matera il fucile con
tutto il rispetto per te di ma a parte
di fucile
usciamo raggiunge su veloci ma no ma non
mia ma non è vero ma non è vero sulle
scale alla ca ga re ma dai
cioè per essere per telefono non è male
se proprio vogliamo dei 10 milioni di
scaricamenti ok io spero che questo vi
sia piaciuto granny l'ho fatto come ci è
riuscito a volte mi piace che ora come
ci siete e non ci vediamo
[Musica]